y
[Música]
nuevo confinamiento en 16 departamentos
de francia incluida parís el primer
ministro galo young castex anunció
cuatro semanas de confinamiento estricto
ante el aumento de los contagios y el
alto nivel de ocupación de las unidades
de cuidados intensivos la medida entrará
en vigor a la medianoche de este viernes
tenemos reportes desde parís
españa se convirtió hoy en el séptimo
país del mundo y el cuarto de europa en
legalizar la eutanasia el parlamento
aprobó el proyecto de ley que
despenaliza la ayuda médica y garantiza
el derecho a morir dignamente a los
mayores de edad que sufran es de una
enfermedad grave e incurable o
imposibilitan t
y cuando se cumplen 10 años del inicio
de las protestas que llevaron a la
cruenta guerra civil que se vive en
siria la ciudad no tenga de raqqa
empieza a volver a la normalidad nuestra
enviada especiales nos presenta un
informe con imágenes pocas veces vistas
en los últimos años ciudadanos jugando
fútbol o jóvenes bailando al aire libre
se aprecian hoy en día en la ciudad
[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva tarde de
información de américa latina y del
mundo aquí en france 24 mi nombre es
liliana valencia iniciamos hablando de
parís porque la capital francesa junto a
otros 16 departamentos del país entrará
nuevamente en confinamiento estricto
durante un mes a partir de este viernes
19 de marzo así lo anunció el primer
ministro de francia jan castex con el
objetivo de contener un nuevo repunte en
los contagios los colegios y comercios
esenciales permanecerán abiertos desde
parís nuestra periodista erika olavarría
nos entregó detalles de lo anunciado por
el gobierno
esos departamentos incluyen el de la
ciudad de parís pero también varios del
norte de francia y en la costa
mediterránea el departamento que incluye
a niza en esos lugares a partir de ahora
las personas para desplazarse ya sea
pedir al médico hacer las compras e
incluso para hacer deportes van a
necesitar de un permiso pero ojo sin
limitación horaria y podrán alejarse
hasta 10 kilómetros de sus hogares los
comercios no esenciales estarán cerrados
en esos departamentos solo abrirán los
esenciales entre ellos también las
librerías y las disquerías las escuelas
elementales y los colegios que reciben
hasta niños de 11 años seguirán abiertos
en cambio los liceos de educación
secundaria solamente van a recibir a un
50% del alumnado las universidades van a
seguir como hasta ahora esto es una
parte de clases a distancia y otra
presencial el primer ministro ran caster
llamó a las empresas y administraciones
a privilegiar el trabajo a distancia al
menos cuatro de cinco días a la semana
recuerdo también que los viajes entre
regiones están prohibidos salvo por
motivos imperiosos y qué
el resto de los departamentos tendrá el
toque de queda ahora a partir de una
hora más tarde comenzará a las 7 de la
tarde en vista del pronto cambio al
horario de verano y además explicó el
primer ministro que a partir de mañana
serán retomadas las inoculaciones con la
vacuna de astrazéneca después de que hoy
la agencia europea del medicamento
considerara que es un antígeno seguro y
eficaz
la agencia europea de medicamentos ema y
la organización mundial de la salud
ratificaron su apoyo al uso de la vacuna
de astra génica después de que un gran
número de países europeos la
suspendieron por relacionarla con
coágulos de sangre en varios pacientes
inoculados la entidad sostuvo que no se
encuentra relación entre la vacuna y los
trombos y que su uso genera muchos más
beneficios que contraindicaciones
tras el anuncio países como alemania
francia e italia informaron que
reanudarán la vacunación con la solución
de la compañía anglo sueca este mismo
viernes día en el que se vacunarán el
primer ministro francés yann castex y su
homólogo británico boris johnson
esta es una vacuna segura y eficaz sus
beneficios para proteger a las personas
del cubil 19 con los riesgos asociados
de muerte y hospitalización superan los
posibles riesgos y costos rsc
solamente también concluyó que la vacuna
no está asociada con un aumento en los
riesgos generales de eventos
tromboembólicos o coágulos de sangre en
short block trops cambiamos de
información aquí en las 24 porque la
cámara representantes de eeuu aprobó el
proyecto de ley que busca regularizar la
situación migratoria de los jóvenes
conocidos como dreamers y también la de
los beneficiarios del estatus de
protección temporal con 228 votos a
favor y 197 en contra la medida resultó
favorecida con el apoyo de nueve
representantes republicanos un proyecto
de ley similar fue votado positivamente
por la cámara baja en 2019 pero se
hundió en el senado para entonces de
mayoría republicana y se prevé que pueda
tener la misma suerte en esta
oportunidad
españa se convirtió este jueves en el
séptimo país del mundo y el cuarto de
europa en legalizar la eutanasia con la
aprobación parlamentaria de la ley de
despenalización para esta práctica y que
regula también la ayuda médica para el
derecho a morir los mayores de edad que
sufre una patología incurable o grave
podrán solicitarla en abril próximo
francia iniciará los debates al respecto
en mar y ángulo nos cuenta más
[Aplausos]
con aplausos frente al congreso fue
recibido el anuncio de la legalización
de la eutanasia en españa la aprobación
de la ley que se dio con 202 votos a
favor 141 en contra y 2 abstenciones
permitirá que dentro de tres meses
cuando entre en vigor la legalización el
territorio español se convierte en el
séptimo de reconocer este derecho tras
bélgica países bajos nueva zelanda
luxemburgo canadá y colómbia es un día
importante para toda la ciudadanía
porque avanzamos hacia una sociedad más
humana y más justa pero sobre todo es un
día importante para aquellas personas
que se encuentran en una situación de
grave padecimiento además de hoy no sólo
empezamos a legalizar la eutanasia y de
conquistar un derecho
hoy también emprendemos el camino para
que este derecho esté incluido como una
prestación más en la cartera de
servicios del sistema nacional de salud
mejorando de este modo nuestra capacidad
asistencial ante la aprobación nos
hicieron esperar las reacciones tanto a
favor como en contra
me siento feliz me siento tranquila
porque tenía un pacto con mi esposo y le
dije que seguiría luchando por esto
justo después de su muerte y hoy lo
logramos hoy es el día de la victoria lo
hicimos para que sea un día muy feliz
pues hoy es un día triste porque hoy
venimos aquí a reclamar nuestro derecho
a la vida donde el derecho fundamental a
la vida y a reclamar nuestro derecho a
la libertad también porque con esta ley
no se deja ninguna libertad a los que
sufren y se les empuja a tomar la
solución más rápida que es la muerte
quienes podrán solicitar la otan asia
serán los mayores de edad que presenten
una enfermedad grave o incurable que les
genere sufrimiento psicológico o físico
constante e intolerable según lo
aprobado el solicitante deberá confirmar
varias veces el deseo de seguir adelante
con el proceso y podrá desistir en
cualquier momento
se cumplen 10 años del inicio de las
protestas en cydia que llevaron a la
mortífera guerra civil que aún se vive
en el país durante los tres años que el
estado islámico domino raca deportes
como el fútbol estaban vetados pero
ahora esta y otras actividades lúdicas
que estaban prohibidas han ido volviendo
a ganar terreno a pesar de las
dificultades económicas y la precariedad
que se vive en la ciudad este es un
informe de nuestra enviada especial
catalina gómez ángel
este saque de esquina es una victoria
para este equipo aficionado de raqqa
durante los tres años que el estado
islámico tuvo el control de la ciudad
era impensable un partido de amigos como
éste
esto significa mucho para nosotros en
ese momento nuestra rutina era trabajar
y la casa no había la capacidad para
hacer deporte ni la tranquilidad mental
para practicarlo
y si es prohibía cualquier actividad
lúdica incluido la televisión los libros
y el fútbol
la librería de agua siempre por la
preferida de los intelectuales cuando
hice estuvo el control de la ciudad las
nuevas autoridades aseguraron que sus
libros eran inmorales se les dijo que
hicieran lo que quisieran con ellos
prefería salvar su vida les dije que era
viejo incluso si se movía en las paredes
y las quemaban no me iba a importar
watán balda frank
hoy esta librería apenas tiene unos
cuantos títulos a cnet se queja de que
pocos quieren leer pero aún así quiere
volver a ofrecer la mejor variedad de
títulos de la ciudad es casi imposible
traer libros harraca es muy difícil
porque estamos casi bajo embargo estos
pocos libros vienen de instituciones
en esta plazoleta de naím que
decapitaron cientos de personas pero la
nueva generación busca dejar atrás este
dolor
somos estudiantes de instituto estamos
en descanso y venimos a divertirnos
estos jóvenes se atreven a bailar en
público pero no hablar del pasado
especialmente de los tiempos de isis
ochoa no no hablaré que hable otro
el futuro de raqqa como el de siria es
incierto pero aquí muchos están
dispuestos a seguir luchando por sus
pequeños espacios de libertad
así finalizamos por esta emisión pero
ustedes pueden continuar con más
tempranas 24 punto como por supuesto
aquí con nosotros que desde con más de
nuestra programación
[Música]